[Music]
good Keanu Reeves background times next
Person of the Year this change.org
petition with over 50,000 signatures is
demanding it you must be aware of this
insane viral thing that's going on with
you lately that Keano is too good for
this world it's been really nice
petitioners even calling Keanu the
respectful King and the most wholesome
person alive carried away with that but
it's nice when it's nice but let's give
him credit the 54 year old bachelor is
clearly having his best year ever
it's really special for me I just have a
John wick film was received also you
know just recently would always be my
maybe and then CD Projekt RED gonna be
here with Toy Story 4 there's a lot of
fun oh yeah
and now it has been revealed piano is
currently on top of Marvel's wish list
yep the company admits they often reach
out to the superstar to join their
blockbuster universe and seems pretty
fitting that the next title given to
Hollywood's current if guy could be
superhero
[Music]